i watched murder on the orient express
for the first time ever yesterday
just cause i heard this trailer was
coming out what'd you think
well john i gotta say i was really
disappointed
that not at one point in the movie did
they play this song
make me make me unbeliever when i saw
that trailer i was like wow this song
works so perfectly
and then i was watching this whole movie
going where's it in the movie where's
the original score
why imagine drag a letdown
let's see what cover songs and death on
the nile
because you know they gotta well they
really set it up for it there's a
murderer on the nile so
yeah it was all right it's okay i didn't
think it was as bad as some people
thought
or or as good as the people i watched if
it was a
netflix original it would have been like
perfect you didn't need so much cgi
it was all right
[Music]
the romance of the desert
oh snap that's army hammer yo yeah oh
yes
he's gotta have a big cast yeah
by jealousy
oh it's her too yeah yeah she looks
wicked familiar
sure
she doing an american accent
maybe
i have investigated many crimes
latisha latisha right
the shape yeah my soul i am detective
and i will deliver your killer
he's aged a lot in between
[Applause]
oh it's not a cover it's just like a a
different
mix of this song
dead and death is the continuation
all right oh boy it's chit chat so
hercule's saying that
this crime altered the shape of his soul
i thought that happened a few days ago
on the orientation
yeah i mean especially with that whole
grave i mean i don't want to spoil that
movie for anybody but the ending is yeah
pretty great
for him especially he learns a great
lesson
but there's a big lesson that he he
learns and it really goes against his
philosophies
yeah and he has to adapt here i
like this trailer a way more than i like
the murder on the orient express
trailers
from what we're getting visually it
looks less reliant
on cgi while there's some cgi touch-ups
here and there
yeah it feels like it's mainly grounded
in the production design the actual
mood and mystery of it feels a lot more
palpable there was something that felt a
little made for tv
about murder on the orient express i
don't know what it could be i mean the
fact that murder on the other express
already had so many adaptations this has
less adaptation keyword being less
so maybe they're able to do a little bit
more of what they want
but it feels more focused murder on the
iron express had this big ensemble with
more famous actors than what you got
here yeah it's like a lot of these
actors are famous
but it seemed like for murder and the
owners are like what are like some
huge huge huge we could just keep
listening here yeah and then here i'm
like
half these people i really know yeah the
other half i recognize and i'm like i've
seen you be really great and stuff yeah
i'm just excited for the ensemble
you know whereas like this whole thing
with you know the desert can be
seductive and
i feel some of that like film noir
romance
death detective mystery solving like it
feels like there's an actual tone here
yeah yeah yeah and even some of that
intrigue that comes with not
like the swashbuckling action of a film
like the mummy but that old time like oh
the wonders of
egypt and the pyramids and whatnot and
yeah i thought this trailer definitely
played well as its own piece
even the 80s tune didn't distract me i
thought you know like it was well
chosen even though it was a pop tune and
yeah it got me interested
in both paro's experience as a character
and
the you know the overall mystery because
one thing i
am curious about is if he keeps doing
these movies will he grow into that
character to the point where i really
feel
like oh yeah he's really made this
character his own
right because with the first one it's
like i liked his performance but at the
same time i wasn't like
losing myself in dupoiro and not seeing
kenneth brenna that's something else i
kind of came to think about while
watching this and yeah
this played like a nice little piece
that teased everything
i actually would hope for from something
like this what we're looking at with
army hammer and gal gadot especially and
whoever that other chick is at yeah
i don't know i don't know who that is
she looks so familiar yeah it
feels a lot more focused on the
characters we'll be really paying
attention to you know for murder on the
oran express
i think that that was a big problem that
i had with it
especially if i had seen it in theaters
was i was way more intrigued with johnny
depp
because i feel like he was the one we
really got to know yeah
everyone seems so surface level yeah and
then here i feel like we're actually
for some of them at least we'll be
getting some real characters that we can
be invested in and probably be concerned
about
gal gadot it seems like especially will
be that character i don't know the death
of the nile story
um i didn't know the murder on the
orange express story either but with
looking at this trailer i i
hope kenneth branagh will take notes
from whatever criticisms were given
towards murder on the earnings
because while it was a box office hit if
you look on rotten tomatoes especially
it has like a 61
on critics and like a 50-something
percent on audience score
so there's definitely a lot of criticism
uh drawn towards that
i know he's coming off of the hit disney
plus from artemis fowl
this one also too yeah looks like that
much more of a film and it looks darker
and it looks heavier
like the murder aspect is gonna be
weighing on the movie and i think that's
a good thing too to take this to a
slightly darker place
yeah man and russell bran looks cool
it's i forgot he actually
no i didn't think he still acted he just
shaved his beard down a little bit and
he's ready to go
because i love who russell brand is now
like his i love his podcast i love
whenever i see him on interviews now
like who he's
turned into with this sort of like
spiritual dude yeah to me he's even
funnier now i
didn't know he was in this movie so
seeing him i was like what russell
brand's acting still i didn't for some
reason i just thought he wasn't acting
anymore
and now i feel just a little bit happier
yeah just the prospect and especially
for something like this the first one
had this element of feeling like i was
watching a play or something like that
and like you said with the surface level
elements of some of the characters it
often just got me excited to see who
could act
next to who else yeah whereas this makes
me feel like maybe it'll be an absorbing
tale of characters more than me just
going look at all these great actors
who are trying to elevate this
lackluster script
based on a book that i'm sure was much
more interested in this
this guy right here that i have a freeze
frame on he's the dude who brought him
on the already express right i believe
so i believe that's him
it's amazing research can do for us we
just typed it in
no no no people in the comments got to
keep us honest yeah that's how we engage
and leticia wright i hope she gets a
rich role there's a
like a lot of people in heroes as
expected but
it's not everyone was like super famous
in the last one
yeah when i noticed there i mean i i
wonder about leticia wright's character
in this too because on the first one
they do
you know at least talk about some kind
of race issues in the movie because of
the time that it's set in and this is
set on a boat with like a
a black wait staff like you can at least
see and i'm wondering if leticia
wright's character may also play into
certain societal things at the time too
no no a few days ago on the orni express
they solved they solved racism on the
orientation
it was a very feminist murder if you go
back and look at it
it's all changed by this yeah yeah let's
change the soul for the better
it's murder all right guys well
murder on the uh nope death on the nile
what'd you think of this trailer
leave your thoughts down below guys
subscribe click that notification bell
if you like this trailer or video hit
the like button
last but not least
paul pj pandey mcjones
now pj stands for pandemic jones but
what does
paul stand for yeah well we're gonna
tell you guys
right now p does not stand for pennis
no it stands for pensive
paul is a pensive guy and paul is also
an attentive guy that's what the a in
paul stands for
and the u stands for
undermine he constantly undermines his
family members
at barbecues yeah and the l stands for
lethargic
he's a lazy dude doesn't like to do much
and that's what undermines his family
because they
are all ninja warriors and that's what
led into
the pandemic jones that's right he was
like i gotta get everybody on the couch
like me
how make him sick sincere shout outs is
the way we're going this month
definitely man i hope you appreciate it
uplifted by these words
and uh encouraged by the sentiments
behind them
just kidding paul love you bud thanks
for being here man
hope you can catch a stream soon we'll
uh we'll catch up
shortly almost some of the umbrella
academy and then dc
fandom and then i'll finally get back to
your messages life will resume is normal